everyone that does youtube eventually
runs into some people in the comments
that aren't exactly pleasant it doesn't
really matter who you are or what you do
and the bigger you are the more likely
you are to encounter these people
and then you kind of come to some kind
of conclusion or you work on it or it
messes with your head and there's a lot
of different ways to handle this
so yeah it happens occasionally now
there's a pretty simple theory that says
about 1 in 100 people are completely
insane
and are impossible to reason with so
naturally as videos tend to get over a
hundred views
uh you're gonna run into some of these
people and the more views it gets the
more people you see in the comments
so
i've definitely run into a few and i'm
just gonna address some of those and let
you know kind of what i think now i will
say for the most part
most comments on my channel are very
nice and and pleasant and uh there's a
lot of thanks for people who have like
learned from my videos and stuff like
that
so that that's good but every once in a
while someone comes in and just
i can't tell if they hate me or if they
hate the world or if they hate
themselves it's a really confusing
situation to address
but uh
i think most people eventually come to
the conclusion that the best thing you
can do is ignore them because if you try
to address them even in a nice way it
only fuels the fire and uh if you stand
up for yourself well it becomes content
and
probably actually helps the channel
so it's it's a really tricky situation
to get right though and i want to
address one here from my uh our
machinery video because
apparently it caused a bit of
controversy i'm not even entirely sure
why so we're gonna we're gonna just like
i'm just gonna talk you through my train
of thought as i read these comments and
why i responded the way i did and i'll
admit a few mistakes here and there
uh so let's have a look shall we now
there are some good ones i'm going to
skip over those because well i guess
they're not as clickbaity drama
interesting
uh let me see let's go to this screen
here
all right so yeah you may have seen it
may not but it's just the shut down our
machinery video i did a a video trying
to explore and figure out what happened
ultimately didn't really figure out what
happened because that info isn't
publicly available and that's basically
what we figured out in the video so
there's there's a little background
context
and uh
yeah some people just weren't extremely
upset by that and i don't know who these
people are i feel like they might be
shills for uh someone on the team or
something like that
i don't really know it's hard to say so
i just have to i just have to guess so
jared says should probably change the
title of the video
i don't know why i should change the
title of the video there isn't any
reason stated here so i was a bit
confused by that now it's true that
youtube is a bit of a click-baity place
like if you're looking for something
uh if whenever you find an exact match
there's a pretty good chance that that
exact match is actually some sort of
clickbait in the video something else
that's just the way youtube is that's
the way people have learned to survive
is by
putting titles on their videos that's
most likely to give them clicks that's
not really the fault of the youtubers we
just kind of have to adapt and make it
as good as we can in that regard as far
as
people clicking it in order to survive
that really has nothing to do with
anyone uh i'm probably the the least
egregious of channels doing this i try
not to click bait in general sometimes i
might a little bit accidentally
sometimes i might a little bit on
purpose
this one i would say was an accident i
didn't intend on it being click bait
but apparently it turned out that way to
jared and i don't know why he doesn't
explain further but maybe he does later
oh yeah he does okay so not null piped
and pretty pointless to post a video of
your investigation when you found
literally no useful information
whatsoever don't you think that was not
null's comment i was a little confused
by this because as far as i know and i
haven't heard any different especially
even from these two it'd be nice
apparently you guys have more
information that you're not sharing why
are you hiding information well there's
no more information at the time of the
video as far as i could tell and as far
as i've heard and i haven't heard any
different
we found all the information available
all right so if that's literally not
useful information then why i don't know
why you're watching the video
all right i'm sorry that it's all the
stuff that's out there is not useful to
you that's really not my fault is the
point so i'm not sure what the point i
guess the point of my video became that
we don't know because they're not saying
or something like that but when i
started making the video my intention
was to find the truth and when i started
the video i did it as a one shot i hit
record i started to
started diving in and just kind of
recording what i found as i found it and
i call this a live cast style
that might be technically wrong
but it's basically where i don't do
reshoots or anything like that it's just
a one shot
video there's not a big script there's
actually no script other than the base
idea of trying to find as many details
as we can
so that's just that was just the style
of the video and
since i didn't really know what else to
say i kind of just gave him that
explanation that hey that's the reality
of live cast videos and you know i
thought this was an okay comment i
thought it would be okay
you can only go so far and i think we
found it of the trail for now
and i just told him that i i disagree
with this why wouldn't i post
why wouldn't i post it it's all the info
it was you know i watched some other
videos on the subject and they had less
info than mine are you also harassing
them about this
go harass them be consistent not nolan
jared go harass every youtuber that
covers our machinery just kidding don't
actually do that i don't condone that
but i'm just saying
it something doesn't add up here
so he came back and uh no mention of
there's more info or anything useful
just this isn't a live stream it's a
video you chose to publish after the
fact
which is absolutely true and i thought
that was totally understood already so
i'm not sure why he's saying all that i
guess he saw this live cast style and
decided that i was saying it was a live
stream which i can see how maybe that's
a little confusion there's the live cast
in the live stream words you know a
little mix up there but i didn't say it
was a live stream and that's not what i
meant so say sorry about the confusion
maybe i'll try to figure out maybe i'll
start calling them one-shot videos this
is a one-shot video and this is not a
live stream can okay is that clear not a
live stream here just a one just a one
shot video all right i'm not doing a
bunch of takes no script just one shot
all right got it not null i know it's i
know it's hard so
when i read this i was uh i was even
more confused at first i thought i
didn't say it was a live stream where
did you get that from
and then i read the rest and i was like
well yeah
i
what so i went up and read my comment i
was like did i say it was a live stream
no i said it was a live cast style
that's the reality of these live cast
style videos okay okay maybe i shouldn't
use live whatever all right i'll take
the blame on that one but you're still
responsible for sounding like a jerk
all right that's that's on you not null
but i i kind of thought this person was
maybe not all that bright that's that's
what crossed my mind when i read this i
was like oh this guy's not very smart i
don't
think i can talk reason to this person
this might be one of the one and one
hundreds that's absolutely insane it
doesn't matter what you say and same
with jared as far as i know which he
reveals that he absolutely is a little
later
so uh yeah i responded back to not know
when i i said uh
you know i just basically treated him
like an idiot and i apologize for that i
shouldn't have done that but it is what
it is and it's up there and i'm not i'm
not going to pretend that i didn't do it
because yeah i was very annoyed
so
i i apologize for how i handled myself
during that annoyance but that it is
what it is okay so yeah that's what i
said i basically gave him a little
uh little talk here at the beginning
that said i know you're not that bright
uh regrets i regret saying that but
whatever i didn't say a live stream i
said it was a live cast style okay
obvious correction you know the words
are right there i didn't really need to
say it because it's so obvious but i
thought i had to spell it out because he
wasn't like me adding one one and
one and one were not adding to two in
his case it was something else was going
on here a little little brain
malfunction
so
yeah and then i you know i said nice job
on the second part of your statement you
got that right
i don't know what else to say
this is a terrible response don't
respond like this
i regret it but i'll leave it you know
i'll own it so jared pipes and he's like
oh this is my chance this is my chance
to look like an idiot
and he does he's he first of all he
proceeds to
uh laugh
just completely
cackle maniacally
uh his butt is gone it's off it's just
just hilariously laughing
but quickly typed you you called your
live cast finding the real story yeah
that's that's what i was attempting to
do
there's uh
no innuendo in there that's what i was
attempting to do sorry if i didn't get
there i don't think it's available
that's what it turned into i know that
it hurts it hurts i'm sorry jared you're
not going to get everything and you want
in life and if you bicker at everybody
you're going to get even less that's the
way it works as if you didn't just waste
20 minutes learning absolutely nothing
what do you mean why do you guys keep
drilling on this i we we went through
everything 100 of the info
was displayed in that that video if you
guys got some angle that i haven't found
post it say something no one said
anything certainly not the people
complaining you have said nothing you
have not done anything to further your
point you basically
said that you didn't like what was out
there
you're mad at them for not releasing the
info and you're for some reason taking
it out on me
which is just confusing
so
that there there we go so developer
developer pipes in and backs me up a
little bit which i really appreciate
because i was kind of losing my mind at
this point
like
just dealing with nonsense people that
don't understand reason or just don't
hear like words as they are
is very frustrating i don't know if
you've ever talked to like a toddler or
some small child that doesn't quite
grasp the understanding of a lot of
words yet so you tell them something and
they do something else and it just kind
of happens over and over but it gets to
be a little frustrating i know i've
raised a couple kids but uh
you just gotta have a lot of patience
with them and
i don't know where i'm going with this
exactly other than i basically felt like
i was talking to toddlers you have to
adopt a different mindset i guess is
what i'm saying when you're dealing with
people like this because they don't hear
logic they just need like something else
and it's it's kind of a mystery to
unravel you got to get them to kind of
speak your language you got to go down
to their level
you got to
kind of work your way through all the
gibberish find the in between the lines
and uh i think we found the end of lines
but yeah developer basically just said
that it's interesting to get to know
people making the software behind the
scenes and that's was kind of the
intention so cool someone gets it
so i did respond to uh jared and just
just said odd i did find his response
very odd and his whole demeanor very odd
i still do i still don't get it
uh well i get some of it but it's not
something i can connect with it's he's
just in a bad place in life is what i
gather all right so i just said it's
okay if you don't like it or didn't
learn anything you know it is it's
totally fine i don't expect every
video to be a hundred percent new info
that uh enlightens the world and uh it's
it's perfect and all whatever your
expectation is you're gonna have to
lower it i'm i'm not god all right and
maybe you're figuring that out now after
um
trying to bash me publicly but yeah it's
true i make mistakes definitely not a
god can confirm
yeah can definitely confirm
all right
and i just said
the truth of what i was thinking i'm not
sure i understand how a video puts so
much trouble in your mind i legitimately
don't other than he's got a troubled
mind i would advise ignoring me in my
video and anything that troubles you so
much unless it needs handled that's kind
of different than handle it but there's
nothing you can do about youtube and the
fact that youtube is a clickbait area
and that people try to make titles that
get the most clicks there's nothing you
can do about that jared you're just
gonna have to let that one go
all right so he is
mad all right this makes him mad all
right he doesn't like being told what to
do
he doesn't
like anything probably oh let's just go
with that pretty sure he doesn't like
anything
he and then he responds with the nail in
the coffin that made me nope out of the
conversation he basically explained that
he has no sense of good human nature in
this comment which blew my mind that he
would put this out publicly
but this is where i definitely noped out
because i realized that was dealing with
an absolutely insane person and not just
a toddler mind all right how are you not
ashamed to respond so condescendingly
well i kind of am okay and this is where
he gets it when your channel was utter
crap
whoa okay
so there's two sides to this he wants
to make me feel bad for responding badly
to the person which that's actually fine
i kind of agree with that but
specifically
when your channel was utter crap so only
because he thinks my channel is crap
is it not okay for me to respond like
that now what does this
imply
if my channel was awesome huge great
successful in jared's mind
or in his view
it would be okay
for me to respond
condescendingly to people
so if my channel was great to the next
level where he wanted it to be
this would be
a fine response
yeah
that's what he really thinks so it's
okay for mr beast to treat people badly
it's okay for will smith to treat people
badly anyone that's successful in
jared's eyes it's okay for them to be
terrible but if if you're not you're not
up to jared's par
you you're
you yeah you can't do it all right so
this this told me that he didn't really
but you know he wasn't a logical person
he was one of the the one and one
hundreds absolutely insane don't worry
about me
lol
and he's the the amount of just kind of
cackling maniacally in these comments
that he displays the lammo the lol
just like
just
there's all kinds of emotions he's
laughing he's mad he's upset he's you
know there's just
crazy amount like a back to talk kind of
like a toddler you know like babies have
a lot of they go through a lot of
emotions and it's wild and crazy they
laugh they cry within a minute they
throw tantrums and then then they're
happy again you know that's what that's
the kind of emotion i'm getting out of
these comments it's just
it's baffling man what do you guys think
of this is this is this normal are these
normal youtube comments and i'm finally
just seeing some of them
because uh in general yeah i'm sure bad
comments here and there but i will say
once again
like 99 of the comments on my channel
are perfectly great and fine i love
being corrected i love the scientific
method i like it when people bring new
info i like it when people correct me i
like when people say thanks
you know i generally like all these
comments but it's when people just bring
out the nonsense that like there's no
going forward with
or learning from
that's when it's kind of a problem and
it wouldn't be so bad and i could just
ignore it but the problem is like people
are jumping on this bandwagon
of like total nonsense and agreeing with
it and that's when it's like all right
kind of going to step in and say
something like make this video and
yeah
it is what it is
okay
so
i'll be fine and now i won't bother with
your future investigations oh and then
more
more maniacal laughing like wha what is
happening here what's with all the
laughing i don't get it all right
all right
i i guess he's laughing at the situation
but the thing is
there's just such a display of
various emotions that's the thing like
laughing and it's fine thinking it's
funny is fine but it's the fact that
he's mad and then laughing
and then like it's just all over the
place so it's hard to like understand
his train of thought or be on board with
her or anything like that it's like
impossible basically because it doesn't
make sense it'll just take you for a
roller coaster of nonsense rides
and so at this point i just said thank
you i appreciate it now actually i was
meaning to respond to developer but it
kind of works here i do appreciate a
developer developer thank you but i was
also replying to jared just saying thank
you basically what i gathered here is
he had showed me his true colors
he gave me an understanding of who he
was
and basically told me that
i should definitely never engage with
him again so you know thank you for
showing me that kind of needed to see
that because i was kind of taking you
halfway seriously and trying to
understand you for a minute but you
basically said that that's not possible
i'm impossible to understand
so
all right thanks i appreciate you
telling me that saves me a lot of time i
don't need to dig in any further
all right and developer pipes in a
little more and basically just kind of
insults them a little bit
which
you know
i don't really want to be the mediator
too much i typically don't like it when
people do this in my comments but i feel
like in a way he kind of deserved it
like and maybe he needed to hear it
because basically the way he was acting
is not indicative of
what we try to
go tours on this channel you know it's a
lot of self-betterment it's a lot of
learning it's a lot of getting over the
difficult humps of of coding and
programming and computer science
and uh basically developers says hey man
by the way you're responding i don't
think you got it in you you probably
need to rethink it
and jared just responds with uh
you know
rar
rar
you know if my iq would save you maybe
enjoys clickbait as much as you yeah
he's just still still more anger
more anger going out there not sure why
he's mad still not sure
um just didn't like the title i guess
all right so
yeah developer says one last thing and
basically says
that he responded like a low iq teenager
he didn't call him a low iq teenager he
said he responded like one what actually
i actually agree with that he kind of
did respond like that like a low iq
teenager etc
um
it is what it is
so he seems to be wanting to push this
narrative of uh
or the judge
what it was his narrative that i should
change the title
there's definitely a narrative if that
uh you're allowed to treat people badly
if you're successful
he's definitely pushing that narrative
which is awful i do not agree with it or
condone that
i uh
i'm specifically against that to be
clear all right we'll even down vote the
comment i don't think that shows but
whatever
so that's it you know these are rare
this doesn't happen often uh so i
thought i'd highlight it get a few drama
clicks these uh
this video here has done a lot better
than most of my other recent videos so
i thought uh you know i thought about
changing it or taking it down maybe
maybe it was a bad take but it's doing
better than all my other videos and
i'm not you know this isn't my full-time
job i'll say i'd like it to be but it's
not you know it's a side thing right now
will become my full-time i'd love it to
be but it it's gotta like replace
you know it's gotta be feasible it's got
to like replace the income of
my full-time stuff and then it could
become full-time but until then
it's just a side thing
you know
i don't know how much i want to get into
that but yeah if you wanted if you want
me to do this more and spend more time
editing and not do maybe so many
live cast styles
there's definitely ways to support me
you can like
share
leave comments
uh so thanks guys for all the comments
do appreciate it and there's a patreon
you can join as a member there's all
kinds of stuff you can do but
that's the end of this video
uh hopefully this one gets as as many
clicks as the the previous one i want to
specifically thank these two haters for
uh giving me more content and uh ways to
move forward on
on youtube because we all know the drama
gets the most clicks i think this counts
as drama so we'll see what happens and
uh yeah just thank these two for the
context if you really hate the video you
can thumbs down it
no one will ever know it's actually
still supporting me
you can double click it to be super
confusing
to everybody and i guess that's about it
i would appreciate a like
if you are willing to do that and i'll
see you guys in the next one peace out